this is a great course I'm really
delighted to be here so thank you for
the for the invitation and we left this
or Fred and Jamie left this for last
night I think it's appropriate actually
I'm glad that it was last I think it's
an appropriate footnote because probably
the first thing to say is that the use
of medication and autism is really it
should be thought of that in that way
it's a footnote I'll be it it can be a
very important footnote but a footnote
nonetheless and you've covered some of
the more important issues about
diagnosis about assessment and about
treatment without medication I'll talk a
little bit about non-medication
treatments but mostly today we're going
to be talking about what the role of
medication is or should be in autism so
let us get started
so the way I've divided this talk is
into these five parts four of which will
include another video and then when we
turn off the camera if we have time I
have a couple of video examples but the
four things are some general
considerations about medication what
they are how we use them in autism the
second part is lessons learned
especially about things that have not
worked so well things we should be
avoiding but still important lessons to
have been learned from those experiences
the bulk of the talk today is going to
be the third part about these ongoing
efforts things that can be targeted with
medication and what the evidence base is
for that what have we learned
systematically about how best to use
medication in children and adolescents
with autism and finally very briefly
I'll play the role of a reader into the
future and try to look into my crystal
ball and try to make some predictions
with you all about where I think
medication might be going in the years
to come again in the last couple of
minutes after we turn off the video I
have a couple of video examples of
actual kids so let's get started with
some general considerations three three
brief points to get the the conversation
started one about prevalence
and the second one about cost just to
put things into context so three things
that we can say is if medication is
widespread even though I started by
saying that it's a footnote we know from
a number of surveys and from
epidemiology that medications are used
very widely in kids with autism many
different medications have been tried
the history here is somewhat checkered
some things have been very helpful many
things have not helped at all and we
know that psychotropic medications are
costly they cost a lot of money and they
can be a not insignificant part of the
care for autism so to put the prevalence
into context these are three select
studies out of many that have been done
showing very simply what percentage of
kids and adolescents with autism were
treated with some psychotropic
medication any psychotropic medication
and these three examples you see a study
done in Virginia where 70% of kids we're
on some psychotropic medication 52% in
Minnesota and in a very large nationwide
Medicaid study 56% so roughly about
two-thirds of kids at any given time are
in some kind of psychotropic medication
but that in in contrast with the
footnote comment that I've made at the
start now this is a snapshot of the
United States if we look around the
world and this is just one example this
is from Spain from the Basque region of
Spain that happens we have a very good
birth throughout life cradle-to-grave
system of treatment for autism and in
this region where there are lots of
interventions including psychosocial
interventions home based interventions
appropriate housing appropriate medical
care free of cost for everyone we know
from this rarefied and very specialized
setting in the world that for them over
the last 10 years they have had
virtually the same rate of medication
used which is
percent and it hasn't changed at all
across many different medications tribe
it's been a remarkably steady rate so I
don't want to read too much into this
but the point to be made is that the
more systematic approaches that we have
for approaching individuals with autism
the more interventions that we have
sometimes the less relies that we need
to have on medication and we see them
across the United States a very
disparate rate of medication use and yet
here is it in this one example we see a
highly consistent rate over time let me
go back to the United States and give
you another example of some other things
going on in the United States and to put
it into context this is I think the only
cartoon that I have but hypocracy z-- we
know the father of medicine and drogas
the father of dentistry and then of
course we have Vanilla's the father of
upward spiral of healthcare costs and
it's there's a point here if you look at
what has happened with medication cost
and with psychiatric costs in the United
States again this is just a snapshot of
what happened in the law in the late 90s
we don't have much reason to suspect
that this has to change significantly
what do you see here I don't don't worry
about the the smaller print here the
larger story is in these three color
graphs what we have in the green is what
has happened to the use and the cost
associated with inpatient psychiatric
care this is not just for kids with
autism this is for all kids with
psychiatric conditions and we see that
in these nine years between these four
years between 1997 and 2001 all these
costs have gone down by about 20% 20%
fewer kids in the hospital 20% fewer
payments less less less in the dark blue
we see a similar story for outpatient
services it turns out that there are
fewer outpatient services that the
reimbursements are less and less and
what happens and the light blue here we
happens what has happened with
medication medication cost during that
same period of time have gone up so
we're spending more and more on
medications medication use is very
widespread and sometimes
there's a substitution of comprehensive
care for the simple use of medication
which is certainly not what we're
advocating here it's more of a
cautionary note to get a start in the
case of autism we know less but we know
some this is a study that looked at
costs associated with autism in the
beginning of the 2000s between 2000 and
2004 and what what we have here this is
a different coating in the green we have
what has happened with autism and we
have in the three other colors three
different psychiatric conditions we have
bipolar disorder in the blue attention
deficit disorder in the light blue and
other psychiatric conditions in the gray
what we see is that during these four
years
costs associated with all of these
conditions went up across the board
things got more expensive probably no
surprise more cost whether it was for
medication for inpatient for outpatient
care but we see that the condition that
got pink the the most dramatic increases
in cost shift was autism so in a very
short period of time cost associated
with autism were much higher than for
comparable conditions so the steepest
rise in cost was associated with autism
in this large insured population the
average this is not necessarily
applicable to the individual child but
it went from 40,000 for 10,000
individuals insured to 115,000 so
regardless of the actual number it more
than doubled in a very short period of
time and medication importantly was one
of the key drivers of these costs okay
so so far wit so so much about some
prevalence or some numbers took place of
the conversation in context now moving
from the cautionary notes from what we
don't want to advocate to some more best
practices what we hope will happen and
is increasingly happening in some places
we want again medication to be this
footnote we want medication when used to
be only one part of a comprehensive
treatment approach
importantly we the medications that we
use nowadays are mostly used for target
symptoms for problematic behaviors
associated with autism but not
necessarily for the core symptoms for
the guts of a disorder for the social
impairment for example we don't as of
yet have medications to do to treat that
but we have medications that can be very
helpful for some of the associated
target symptoms with autism and if we
can make an improvement on those we can
make we can have a significant impact on
the lives of children very importantly
medical aspects should not be overseeing
and sometimes easy things such as pain
let's say the pain from a tooth abscess
from a cavity can be a big driver in
some of the behavioral problems that
then we're going to be trying to target
with medications so sometimes rather
than getting fancy and trying to stamp
out behavioral problems with
psychotropic medications having a basic
medical workup might be all that is
necessary another thing not to be over
seen in these kids as a parole
transition and when hormones and sexual
urges and sexual development come online
that can really be a tremendous driver
of some of the behavioral changes that
then in some efforts were trying to
medicate away going to these Corvette
vs. target symptoms so by now you should
all be experts in knowing that the core
symptoms of autism and related disorders
fall into these three main categories
impairment in social interaction
certainly being the the most important
one
restrictive and repetitive behaviors and
interests and problems serious problems
in communication and language
unfortunately we don't have any real
medication to target any of those things
but what we do have our medications that
can be quite helpful in aggression in
self-injury seizures and this is
intended to represent the overshadowing
of co-occurring psychopathology the
point here being that having autism does
not immunize those children or
adolescents young adults from having
other psychiatric pathology in fact
there's a higher
expression of other types of psychiatric
disorders anxiety depression whatnot in
children with autism and sometimes
there's this overshadowing effect where
people think everything is a consequence
or explained by autism so this is a
reminder that we should be paying
attention to these underlying
co-occurring psychiatric pathologies
again not all problems are always
explained by autism it is very easy to
oversee even common psychopathology
intellectual disability for sure mental
retardation that can be present in
two-thirds three-fourths of kids with
autism depression and anxiety these
become particularly serious problems
during adolescence during young
adulthood adulthood with when some of
these individuals particularly the more
higher-functioning ones might start
seeing that there's something awry
though there's something immense that
they can't quite connect the way they
would like and then as a consequence of
that they get depressed they get anxious
attention deficit disorder is common and
a frank psychosis can happen in in
autism and it's very difficult sometimes
to disentangle these serious pathologies
we do know for example that seizures are
over represented as much as fourfold
more dr. Folkman are actually wrote one
of the seminal papers showing that
seizures are widely over-represented in
autism and the same may be true for
psychosis and other forms of serious
pathology now the DSM the the Bible if
you will that we use for psychiatric
nomenclature has been very helpful but
it has introduced some sticky points and
one of them is this problem with
parsimony and that DSM really
discourages making other diagnoses so
that if we have a child with serious
problems with attention and
hyperactivity we're discouraged by DSM
for rules to make a diagnosis of ADHD
now that may or may not be important but
in the context of talking about
medication it is relevant because
sometimes is if we think that everything
is explained on the basis of autism we
would not give some of these kids
potentially beneficial treatments
okay so moving on to the second part
autism has the unhappy news of probably
being the condition at least in
psychiatry in child psychiatry for which
the most weird and varied types of
useless interventions have been applied
most of the times by well-meaning people
but sometimes not this is just a very
select brief representation of some of
the things that have been tried aerelon
lenses facilitated communication
psychoanalysis psychic or cranial
therapy animal assisted therapies
packing lip packing something that is
still applied and in vogue in France
where children are wrapped with wet
towels and while they're in this
condition they are talked about their
unconscious and the story just gets
crazier there are many things that
really fall close to or not close to
fall squarely in unethical and really
unproven treatments anti my Kotik
treatments two of the probably more
relevant recent ones that may ring some
bells one has to do with a whole
controversy about autism and trying to
use about vaccinations and autism and
about these efforts to use chelation
chemicals medications to chelate to
bring down the allegedly abnormal levels
of heavy metals for example these
interventions can and themselves be
quite dangerous and there have been at
least a couple of deaths associated with
the use of these key later treatments
now secrete and I highlighted here
because although it's a treatment that
has been proven ineffective and I won't
go into all the details of what it is
and so forth just to say that it's been
ineffective but there's a couple of
points to be learned from secreting this
is a screenshot from a study showing not
just that one study or two studies or
three studies were negative but that 15
double-blind controlled studies had
schon without the shadow of a doubt that
this intervention didn't help us
initially suggested 15 studies as you
will see when I describe what works and
what has been tested we'd be lucky if we
had 15 studies overall and yet 15
studies were dedicated to this one
intervention that proved to be a lost
cause so what are some of the things
that we could learn from this and again
Fred wrote a relevant editorial about
this it's very easy to go from a hopeful
message one child responded to secretin
to really running with it and at that
time a decade ago secretely really
captured the imagination of the public
and in a very short period of time
during four years there were 600
individuals who were randomized to
receive secretin versus placebo to this
day secretest remains the most
extensively studied intervention
pharmacologically in autism there was
this was a huge federal investment of
dollars and there was absolutely no
evidence of efficacy so all of this is a
real downer and this is really negative
and you know why am I telling you this
story
well the silver lining in this story and
I think it's a an important one is that
all of this was pushed really by
consumer family advocate groups autism
has really taken a lead in vocal
proactive parents and support groups who
have really placed things on the map and
although this particular cause didn't
yield the results that we would have
hoped these same groups are the ones
that have placed autism in such a
positive way in the public's opinion
it's why we have these kinds of courses
it's why we're on YouTube it is why
federal funding for autism has increased
to the level so that it has so I think
that that's one of the good pieces of
the secretin otherwise sad story
now moving from that into some of what
we do know there have been major
advances over the past decade and at
least partly really spurred by these
advocacy efforts by families and
involved others the four 2000 the year
2000 there were very few studies done
with autism and the ones that we had
were with very small samples fewer than
100 children which is really not much to
say anything decisively some of the
challenges have included the recruitment
to studies is a very challenging
proposition it's very hard to find
children and families who will agree to
be enrolled in these studies and the
corollary of this is that most of these
studies that I'll describe had to be
multi-site efforts many different sites
coming together in order to identify and
recruit sufficient number of children
studies like these are extremely costly
and time-consuming and the federal
funding is absolutely critical for them
in IMH the National Institute of Mental
Health and ni CHD the National Institute
for child health and development are two
of the main funders of these large
studies and luckily for us the evidence
base is growing there are certain things
that we can say today about do's and do
nots in the use of medication that are
based not just on personal opinion but
on actual data and that is all good news
so let me try to deconstruct that a
little bit for us the way that I'll do
this is by talking about some of the key
target symptoms that can be effectively
targeted with medication as I said the
core symptoms as of today cannot be
really modified much with medication but
some of these other target symptoms can
the first one and probably the one where
we're doing the best is irritability
aggression self-injury property
destruction all of these things that can
make really impossible to live with a
child with autism because one thing is
to be ignored if you will by your child
or not to to help
the kind of intense emotional contact
that you would like with a child and
that is very painful but if in addition
to that your child is destroying the
house and hitting you and kicking you
and biting you
it takes the challenge into a whole
other level and medication can be
actually quite helpful for that as I'll
describe the other two target symptoms
that I'll describe where we haven't done
quite as well
our hyperactivity and inattention and
repetitive behaviors so let's start with
some of this aggression the the core
treatments that we use for aggression
are what we call atypical antipsychotics
antipsychotics and this may be very
basic for some of you but just so that
we all are on the same page
antipsychotics are medications that we
have used since the 1960s for the
treatment of a range of serious
psychopathology traditionally
schizophrenia the traditional
antipsychotics all have effects on the
dopamine synapse and this is a cartoon
of our friend the dopamine synapse where
we have a pre synaptic cleft a post
synaptic cleft and dopamine is released
into the synaptic space and the key
mechanism through which antipsychotics
work is by blocking the attachment of
these dopamine molecules to the dopamine
receptor and particularly a d2 a
dopamine two type of receptor that is
the main mechanism affection for these
medications now we know that these
traditional antipsychotics have been
effective in small randomized controlled
trials in autism that was good news and
be small fewer than 100 children cases
but there were some problems associated
with them and particularly this thing
called tardive dyskinesia which is a
long-lasting permanent side effect a
movement disorder typically of movements
or movements around the mouth and the
face that can be permanent cannot go
away even though the incidence of that
was relatively small it wasn't something
that we saw much it was concerning and
that it was an irreversible side effect
that was part of the reason why we have
moved over the last decade almost
completely to what are called atypical
antipsychotic
atypical antipsychotics also work on the
dopamine system but they have other
effects they also work under certain
certain in' system and importantly they
have a much lower risk of these tarted
dystonias and dyskinesia and they seem
to be quite promising in small samples
and small k-series of children with
autism two more things about dopamine
and the antipsychotics this is a cartoon
of the key brain pathways involved in
dopamine transmission so these are some
of the places where these antipsychotic
medications work there are projections
that go into the frontal cortex that
have to do with some of the higher
functioning activities of the brain but
they also go into some of these deeper
structures of the brain and some of this
has to do with it has relevance to some
other side effect profile for example
weight gain appetite increase some are
are things that are handled in deeper
brain structures in the hypothalamus and
the thalamus this is a cartoon very
similar to the first one showing again a
dopamine synapse and showing that these
atypical antipsychotics not only work on
dopamine as we saw in the first cartoon
but they also have effects on the
certain urge ik transmission so they are
mixed agents that have effects on both
dopamine and serotonin and this may
explain why they are more effective they
have fewer side-effects and so forth
okay there are a number of atypical
antipsychotics the most commonly used
one the one we know the best in autism
is risperidone risperidone is the first
of this bunch and it's really a great
thing that here at Yale we were the
primary site and the organizing site for
the key study that proved the efficacy
of respira and it was fair known in
autism and our colleague Larry scahill
was a principal investigator
coordinating this very massive effort
101 subjects which doesn't sound like
much but this took a couple of years to
recruit these subjects the vast majority
consistent with what we know with autism
we're boys the age range was children
and adolescents ages 5 through 17 and
this was a double-blind
placebo-controlled study meaning that
neither the patient nor the
investigators knew what the pill was
that the children were receiving until
after the study was completed this RUP
study RuPt by the way stands for
research units in Pediatrics
psychopharmacology and this network
again coordinated by Larry Scahill here
at Yale consisted of four other sites
UCLA Indiana University in Indianapolis
Ohio State University in Columbus and
the Kennedy Krieger Center in Baltimore
and through these five sites we were
able to accrue sufficient individuals to
do this study what are some of the key
messages of the risperidone study this
is a snapshot of what happened at the
end of the eight weeks of the study you
see here the ratings every two weeks and
very clearly you see the separation
between the group treated with respect
and the group on placebo who stays very
similar over time if we want to give
that some numbers to know is this a
little or is this a big difference in
this particular scale that was used
called the aberrant behavior checklist
children with placebo 52 of them really
didn't change much for points view or
not not a real difference compared to 15
points of decrease and those treated
with respect out to be an effect size of
one point to effect sizes above 0.8 are
considered to be large there are
relatively few actually very few
interventions in psychopharmacology that
have effect sizes this big so the
take-home point is that RISP Erin was
not only effective in autism to reduce
these behaviors of aggression
impulsivity and so forth but that it was
dramatically effective making it one of
the one of the most useful medications
that we have in our current
armamentarium
kids
right so the the question is how to
translate the these kind of statistical
numbers into real what happens with with
kids on at home the the type of
behaviors that that more were most
commonly seen we're hitting aggression
against self some of these there's what
there was a wide variation some kids
we're constantly hitting themselves
we're constantly hitting families some
of them maybe two or three times a week
some maybe once a month but the point is
that wherever they started they had a
dramatic decrease by you know 50 60
percent in very few kids did these
behaviors completely disappear in some
they did but mostly there was a dramatic
decrease so if someone started with 10
times a week let's say having some
episode like this maybe by the end of
the trial were tied one or two a week
another way of quantifying this and
maybe related to to your question is
this was another way of looking at the
same data but here rather than using
that scale the aberrant behavior
checklist we're using this poor man's
scale called the clinical impression
scale which essentially is what you're
asking in my clinical impression as a
clinician or SSO parent who is getting
better and here we see that about 80% of
children treated with respect on got
better compared to only 10 12 % of those
kids treated with placebo in one way of
thinking about this of translating this
into a number more usable with the
patient that we're treating with the
individual child that we have is this
notion of number needed to treat which
again as a variation of what you're
asking a number needed to treat tells us
that if we have that we would have to
treat two children with this similar
behavioral kind of problems before we
saw one of them getting better related
to the medication so to give you a sense
of scale most medical interventions have
an NT a number needed to treat in the 10
to 50 range we need to treat that many
children before we see an improvement
something that has nnnt of to is a
really very very successful in
so we're talking about medications that
are really quite dramatically effective
the main thing for which risperidone was
helpful was irritability this aggression
type of behaviors but the aberrant
behavior checklist this scale that I
mentioned taps into five different
domains social withdrawal stereotypy or
repetitive behaviors hyperactivity and
problems with speech and what we see
here is that there's some difference
starting risperidone in the purple and
risperidone at the end of treatment both
of the purple lines and in the tan lines
we have placebo at the beginning and at
the end of the treatment what we saw at
the end of this trial was that certainly
irritability was the main thing that
improved but there were also some
changes in stereotypy so some of these
repetitive behaviors also got better and
some of the hyperactivity also got
better not quite as dramatically as
aggression but the point is that there
were some other benefits seen with the
use of risperidone in these kids another
important point is that some of these
benefits were not short-lived even
though the trial lasted only eight weeks
were presented here in the green and the
red bars in the green we have the
placebo group and in the red we have the
risperidone group and if you recall that
trial was only eight weeks but in a
subsequent study that went out to 24
weeks we saw that during open label
extension meaning that by now we knew
who was getting the risperidone there
was no longer this deceived with the
placebo whether these benefits were
sustained over 24 weeks in fact later on
when there was an effort to discontinue
in a blinded way again introducing a
placebo to half of the kids and keeping
half of them in risperidone that
particular study had to be stopped
prematurely because virtually all of the
kids who are assigned to placebo very
quickly had a regression in their
symptoms and they needed to be placed
back on
so we know that this medication is
effective that it gives effective in a
range of symptoms and all of this
information particulars is
unique so what next well one of the
things and this is really brand new
information that was just published this
month again Larry Scahill here and some
of his colleagues have taken the lead in
this is that risperidone should not be
used alone and what they have done is
experimentally looking at this can they
complement can we complement a
medication such as risperidone with
psychosocial interventions in this case
with a structured parent training in
this case they used to manualized
intervention 11 sessions 12 sessions
there are a range of didactic materials
that included videos scripts specific
tasks that would be done with a child
reinforcement positive reinforcement for
doing things well some come from channel
communication skills helping the child
better identify needs and wants and
having behavioral rehearsal for problem
problematic behaviors with extensive
feedback and homework in doing this you
won't be surprised to find out that in
the combination group he represented in
in the blue line things went better than
in the risperidone only group the
difference is certainly not as dramatic
and in the past in the previous slide
but the point is that complementing
behavioral interventions to medication
gives the best of both worlds in this
case again we're comparing medication
alone to medication and psychosocial
intervention and seeing the added
benefits of adding
is intervention the FDA as you know is
involved in the marketing and the
branding of medications and the safety
of medications and this is a partial
list of the very few of the dozen or so
medications that have been approved by
the FDA for use in kids under the age of
18 this a partial list but you can see
that most of these medications have been
used for example methylphenidate or
Ritalin has been approved for the Ford
season attention deficit disorder
there's a range of antidepressants that
have been approved for use in
obsessive-compulsive disorder lithium
and mania some antipsychotics for
Tourette Syndrome haloperidol for
explosiveness imipramine for any rhesus
and the list is no much longer than this
I do want to highlight that risperidone
is now part of that list and that
through these studies risperidone is now
one of only a dozen or so medications
that have the FDA blessing and of an
approval to be used in a psychiatric
condition of childhood most of the
medications that we use in children with
psychiatric conditions are used
off-label meaning that a physician can
prescribe them even though the FDA has
not quite approved them for that
indication but when we have these
medications that do have that stamp of
approval it tells us that there has
there has been this additional level of
scrutiny of safety associated with the
medication so all of that is great what
is the bad news that I'm not telling you
or is it all good well there's a little
bit of bad news and and the main bad
news has to do with this side effect
which is weight gain weight gain is the
most important side effect associated
with these medications this is a study
that was published recently not relevant
only to autism but to a range of
psychiatric disorders and children where
270 children were followed over three
months and you see their mean increase
in weight during this time frame you see
that five antipsychotics five atypical
antipsychotics here are all four at four
I'm sorry for it atypical antipsychotics
are all associated with weight increased
olanzapine has a highest weight increase
in average of 8 kilos in three months so
that's a kilo and a half three or four
pounds per month quetiapine another
antipsychotic and here risperidone the
one that we've been talking about an
average weight gain of close to five
kilos over three months so weighting is
the the main problem that we have to
fend with this unremarkable line here is
the untreated group and the smaller
graph here represents era pip result era
pip result is another atypical
antipsychotic that has recently been
tried in autism it is comparable to
risperidone and its efficacy and it
seems to have somewhat lesser of impact
on weight gain you can imagine the
problems associated with weight gain
these are the same data express slightly
differently as percent of body weight
increase so you see weight increases it
goes as much as 15% in the case of
risperidone a weight increase of 10% of
way to increase over three months and
associated with that you can imagine all
the metabolic and physical problems that
go with that we are concerned about kids
who continue to to gain weight what kind
of metabolic problems they might have
down the line including things such as
elevated cholesterol triglycerides
diabetes etc question
does that continue indefinitely we don't
really know but we have a sense that it
does Plateau
somewhere around one year so these kids
don't continue gaming indefinitely but
there is this very dramatic weight gain
over the first three months it's hard to
slow down during the first six months or
so but we don't we don't know
you know it's it's a tricky question
particularly for kids because remember
that kids are also in a normative way
gaining weight so in some ways though
the right question is not how much
weight itself we have fancier ways of
measuring it that have to do with what
are the growth charts that you will
remember from when you went to your
pediatrician you know you're growing at
a steady rate and the question here is
who gets off of that curve through the
effect of the medication and there's a
sizable proportion of those kids my
guesstimate would be that twenty thirty
maybe forty percent of kids gain weight
in that significant weight so not
everybody but a significant proportion
okay so I started with risperidone
because this is a medication we know the
most about and the one that has the best
track record for and even though the FDA
approval as I mentioned but there are
two other classes of medications that
have been tried for inattention
hyperactivity stimulants have been used
the most common stimulant of course is
methylphenidate aka Ritalin and we know
that there's a large body of data for
the use of stimulants in attention
deficit disorder but there had only been
anecdotal reports in autism could these
medications work well they might but
there were also similar reports that
they could worsen problems such as
stereo defeats repetitive behaviors many
concerns that the medication could make
these things worse
could they worsen the irritability that
I just talked about the efforts that we
have done to to stamp out with things
like risperidone and there were also
some reports that these medications
could increase social withdrawal and
isolation so over the last couple of
years we've had some data specific for
autism these medications all by the way
act also on dopamine but in in a
different pathway this is a cartoon of
the synapse and if you recall in the
antipsychotics they blocked the
attachment of dopamine to the
postsynaptic receptors by contrast these
medications of stimulants what they do
is push dopamine out into the synaptic
cleft so they increase the levels of
dopamine whether it is by
inhibiting the reabsorption of dopamine
into these pre synaptic vesicles whether
it's by blocking the reuptake into the
synapse through a range of mechanisms
they push dopamine out into the synapse
and we think that that's one of the ways
through which they work now leaving that
basic science finding aside or
explanation aside what do we know about
how these medications work in kids once
again a multi-site effort much the same
network the RUP network around the
country in this case through a lot of
efforts 72 children were enrolled very
hard to enroll a lot of hesitation about
using these medications and kids with
autism and a very ginger very careful
design in which there was the first week
in which just a very teeny small test
dose was given and if those kids could
tolerate it then they went into a
four-week double-blind phase where they
were given either a placebo a sugar pill
or the the stimulant methylphenidate
ritalin and four different in three
different doses low a medium and a high
it was an eight-week study a four-week
double-blind study followed by an
eight-week extension and what is it that
was found well rather than just showing
you what was found let me compare that
to what we know about the treatment of
ADHD in kids without autism the MTA the
multi I'm blanking on the multi
something I'm blanking about what the
MTA it's one of these things that you
use how much multi-faceted multi
something treatment of ADHD this is the
largest study the the granddaddy of all
ADHD studies and I'm going to compare
what we know from that Rolls Royce study
in kids without autism to what we know
in autism so the first thing is that
most kids respond whether they have
autism or not but we see that the
response rate in the MTA and kids with
regular without autism was close to 80%
most kids respond and respond very
dramatically to
stimulants their inattention their
impulsivity gets better the first
observation is that in the case of
autism the response is not nearly as
much about 40% 50% of kids responded the
second observation is that this is not
accounted by placebo response because
the placebo response across these two
groups was essentially identical so the
kids responded just as poorly to placebo
they didn't respond to placebo when we
try to quantify that we see that
methylphenidate again riddling used
either in a low and a medium or a high
dose seems to have some efficacy for
autism
all of these are effect sizes in the
range of 0.3 to 0.5 compare that to what
we had talked about with autism that
with respect on those effect sizes of
1.2 that were very dramatic so these are
subtle these are small effect sizes
compared to what we know in normally
developing children so normally
developing children riddle ins and
similar medications can have this really
Wow effect something that we don't see
in autism the other thing that we saw in
autism is that discontinuation was which
was much more dramatic we saw that in
the MTA it was a very small fraction of
kids who discontinued treatment during
the double-blind study just a couple of
percentage two three four percentage
percent of kids discontinued in this
trial with autism about 15 percent of
kids discontinued so in summary these
medications can be helpful for the
targeting of inattention and impulsivity
and irritability and attention but not
nearly as much as in normally developing
kids and there are more significant side
effects so these are in the so-so
category the third and last medication
that has been extensively studied in
autism is to target repetitive behaviors
some of these interfering behaviors
where a child will spend a lot of time
doing the same activity over and over
again to the exclusion of more socially
adequate or appropriate activities now
there has been a lot of interest in the
similarity
between some of the repetitive behaviors
and autism and obsessive-compulsive
disorder and we know that there's a very
strong evidence for the use of
medications antidepressant medications
called SSRIs sir selective serotonin
reuptake inhibitors in the treatment of
OCD and that was part of the rationale
for trying these medications in autism
we also know that there is a lot of
evidence and old evidence going back to
the 60s that serotonin metabolism is
abnormal in autism and we have some
preliminary evidence that these
medications are helpful in adults with
autism we also know as I had mentioned
that depression and anxiety conditions
that are targeted by these medications
happen more commonly interests with
autism particularly higher functioning
autism so based on all of this it seemed
like a slam dunk that these medications
would be very helpful in autism again to
bring us all to speed on what these
medications are and how they work this
is a cartoon of a certain urge at neuron
and you see here the presynaptic neuron
the synaptic cleft the post synaptic
membrane and when serotonin is released
it typically applies over long lands on
a serotonin receptor SSRIs or serotonin
reuptake inhibitors block that they
block the reuptake of serotonin back
into the presynaptic neuron with a net
effect that there's this accumulation or
this excess of serotonin in the synaptic
cleft and that is the basic mechanism of
how these medications work now there's a
range of these medications the most
common one of course being prozac or
fluoxetine as I had mentioned there
there was some preliminary evidence done
here in the 1990s by our colleague Chris
McDougall who is now in Indiana
University working with adults with
autism and showing that adults treated
with this particular as is where I
called fluvoxamine which is a cousin a
first-degree cousin of Prozac they
improved quite substantially in their
repetitive behaviors in the case of
fluvoxamine about how
of these individuals improve compared to
none of the adults with autism granted
these were small samples 15 individuals
in each group but this seemed to be
promising information based on this a
very large scale study was done and see
how the sample size keeps on creeping up
we had seen that risperidone study was
101 children by now 149 children in the
same age range same age range 5 to 17
were treated in this blind double-blind
placebo-controlled way with fluvoxamine
this study again was a multi-site study
it was a different group of
collaborators called the Start Network
which is a center of excellence in
autism and some of the usual subjects
UCLA and Yale but also some other
colleagues at Dartmouth the lead author
of the study
Brian Kangas at Dartmouth Mount Sinai
and the University of North Carolina and
Chapel Hill now exciting as this map is
and exciting as a background was the
result where rather not so exciting in
fact as you can see there was no
difference between the group treated
with the antidepressant and that treated
with placebo there was really no
difference and this was through both
this clinical global impression scale
that I had mentioned before or through a
more nuanced way of measuring these
symptoms the Yale Brown
obsessive-compulsive scale in any way
that the study was looked at these kids
really didn't improve and not only was
this medication no better than placebo
but it was also very poorly tolerated
there was an increase in impulsivity and
hyperactivity and insomnia and
behavioral activation a whole problem a
whole set of problems so this study
published in in one of the leading
journals and really a very important
study the importance of it was showing
that this intervention didn't work and
that a widely widespread intervention
was really not justified and if we go
back to the excess of use of medication
the excessive cost now we have some
information some empirically derived
information to tell as well
maybe we shouldn't be using this kind of
medication it may be that seductive as
it sounded to link
obsessive-compulsive disorder and OCD
that may have been overstated so that is
what we know based on the medications
that we have around for the last two or
three slides I want to be a little bit
of of a psychic and try to think of
where where we hope things will go well
on the one hand I think that we're gonna
continue making these very gradual
stepwise slow interventions there's a
number of medications this is just a
select few of the medications that are
being targeted for these range of
symptoms that I mentioned so for example
for irritability and aggression there's
a lot of interest in other atypical
antipsychotics we know that these
medications are very helpful but we know
that they lead to weight gain and other
problems so these are three of the
medications that are being looked at as
possibilities that could have less
weight gain for example so this is not a
radically different new innovation
you're just trying to tweak an already
useful intervention for the case of
hyperactivity and inattention there
wasn't really a whole lot to say for the
methylphenidate if you remember the
response was soso there were lots of
side effects so there's a lot of
attention or interest in other compounds
including guanfacine and a tamoxifen
which are medications that are widely
used in ADHD but that act through a
different mechanism they haven't been
yet tested in autism but there's
interests in them and for repetitive
behaviors there's a new medication
relatively new medication called Willa's
all that has garnered a lot of attention
all of these are again the stepwise
incremental steps that probably won't be
game changers and how we think about the
treatment of autism whether they could
continue providing some relief to
children and families but what are some
of those game changers that I suspect we
may be seeing well one of them comes
from the example of fragile X syndrome
you may have heard fragile X is a common
form of mental retardation it's in fact
most common form of inherited syndrome
of mental retardation and we know that
it's associated with some specific
facial features an elongated face
narrowly set eyes a flattened nose and
this very traditional appearance we also
know that the chromosomes of individuals
with fragile X have some Select have
normalities and that's why the syndrome
is called fragile X because the X
chromosome when looked under a
microscope has this very typical break
and over the last couple of years we've
learned a lot about the machinery inside
of this syndrome which I won't go into
right now but what we do know is that if
we take a snapshot of what the neurons
of individuals with fragile X syndrome
look like we see here in this panel what
a normal sight a neural extension looks
like with all these many spines these
connections between neurons compared to
what happens in fragile X where we have
this smooth sad-looking
neural extension we know that from
visualizing these brains under the
microscope but over the last couple of
years we've learned a lot of what the
underlying molecular genetics of that
are represented here in this cartoon we
know that there's this fragile X protein
that is produced in excess in fragile X
and we know that some new chemical
compounds in a family called M glue are
5 antagonists it's a mouthful and and
that's not particularly relevant but
what is relevant is that these types of
interventions are now being applied to
mice that have a model very similar to
fragile X in mice in these interventions
these chemical compounds that can not
only prevent the development of fragile
X in mice but they can even revert some
of the early phases of the disorder and
this sounds a little bit like science
fiction but we are already starting not
we but others are already starting what
are called phase 1 phase 2 trials of
these compound
humans meaning that the very early
trials that will eventually lead to the
kind of larger trials that I described
where we're still seeing the feasibility
the safety of these compounds in humans
but it may not be too far off that over
the next decade or two and when you are
up here giving this lecture it may be
that by then we have not only
interventions to ameliorate some of the
behavioral problems associated with
autism but really to change the overall
trajectory of the disorder there is a
leap between fragile X and autism for
sure but there's a lot of similarities
and as we learn more about the different
types of autism if you will I think that
some of the clues are going to come from
fragile X from read syndrome and from
other of these disorders so with that
hopeful note of where the future is
going and of those game changers that we
hope to see developed by young bright
minds like you we'll finish off here